Let me summarize. You learned two really important
things that we use every day in robot programming
and they were somewhat complementary. First
we talked about smoothing which took a discrete
path and turned it into continuous smooth path.
And then we turned about how the robot can
follow this smooth path, using a control
mechanism called PID. With this, you can
actually implement quite a bit of robotics,
with no matter what robot you have, apply
a planner, apply a smoother, apply a controller
and it will do just fine. In fact, this is about
the level at which our DARPA Robot Challenge
car won the DARPA Robot Challenge . The
Google car itself has a little bit more juice
in it. It considers the case that the steering
wheel itself has inertia and that the steering
wheel was driven by something called torque
, not by position, but leaving this aside, you
really got a gist out of what’s happening in
robotic driving. And now we’re able to really
control an actual robot. Congratulations,
that is really, really cool.